hello everyone let me just know if
everything is okay if they're sound the
stream health seems to be orange for the
moment but I hope that will improve I
don't know how it was previously hello
hello Nikita hello hon hello Cygnus
tooth Andrew goldstein and and everyone
else so it's just like the previous time
I linked the tournament is in the
description below you have to enter a
password password is all capital letters
YouTube - this time as this is the
second tournament in row that we're
having thank you mister chamber for
mentioning me it's okay we didn't we
didn't start up the stream too early
this time it's 17 minutes before the
start of the stream so far 86 players
last time we had we had over 2,000
players I believe it's something like
2400 and well it was just quite
enjoyable but yeah let's let's fire up a
second step so I don't mess up my my
tournament page let me know if or when
everyone is you know easily entering the
arena if not okay these are all this is
bullet this is three okay while we're
waiting
good luck mr. Aaron let me just fix that
not too much
okay let's just go yes the password is
in the description as usual let's just
grab this pawn so nice pawn exchange
okay we wrap up on let's see let's see
how we how we do with our pawn it's not
the greatest pawn okay I think it'll be
a good phone now okay let's trade off
okay not interested don't want to fix
this pawn structure that quickly let's
go here oh I just I've wondered the back
rank made the good one
alright that was that was very nice
that's what happens when you when you go
for a pawn
yeah well unfortunate as it is you know
it does happen okay we have mr. scott
tenorman's there like in the previous
one
good luck mr. scott tenorman's dad yeah
that was that was a very nice back rank
mate yeah i forgot that there is a delay
to the stream but it's it's a standard
delay i think it's 15 seconds not
anything you know to be worried about
yeah someone did just walked up and down
the stairs that's my girlfriend she's
getting ready for her for her practice
let's go hear some maybe something okay
that's a very nice Bishop okay let's
let's just go here
okay let's transfer the knight here
yeah that's that's annoying to defend
our Bishop huh yeah he does have a lot
of moves
okay let's go like this yeah that was
that was a nice blunder but it it cannot
be prevented let's go here trade off
this little dude okay let's push our
pawns no no you don't
nope let's put our roots behind our past
pawns and just push that seems to be the
appropriate thing okay first we go back
push here go here totally blundered my
queen here okay what time is time so
good game mr. scott tenorman's dad yes
that is that is true I'm in creation
yeah no problem
it was a it was a good back rank mate we
should have we should definitely have
more of those okay so so far 263 players
monkey school in first place then
Ronaldinho with with a very nice rating
of 21 24 then mr. Tudor 2 to 1 1 with 21
23 then all-rounder x2 Nash one Ghanim
make rock VAR add 45 then Aman Aman
Saxena got cup 1 and Alexander missed
all missed all those are the first 10
and well as usual most of the players
will join when the tournament starts and
for those of you who are new to this who
are maybe just joining in the in the
chat and everything it doesn't matter if
the tournament starts you can join like
you can join whenever you want but yeah
good game mr. scott tenorman's that was
just let me just get rid of these old
challenges that are blocking my view of
the new challenges these are unlimited
ok we have we have a fisherboy fisherboy
is challenging to to a bullet and he's
also a leech a supporter so let's let's
let's see what happens
good luck mr. Fischer boy ok we will not
go for the exchange let's go here
sure sure okay
should have gone here yeah this is maybe
not a bad idea okay
triple pin hmm I don't see him getting
out of this one so that was that was
unfortunate okay yeah that's one way to
do it not not the best way but it is
possible let's just prevent him from
infiltrating with the rook and that's
about all that's about it okay let's
push our past pawn let's just grab his
rook but good we gave mr. Fischer boy
let's see 11 more minutes so we do have
time for a few more fast ones I'm not
gonna accept any longer time formats now
as as we do have a tournament to attend
in 10 minutes so basically if I accept a
three minute challenge it'll just be ups
I oh I accidentally went for the
exchange variation that's something I'm
proud of but it's a bullet so I guess
it's it's possible hope my double sound
isn't irritating you too much but it is
it's much easier to to play especially
bullet when when I hear the sound of the
pieces and I don't feel like wearing
headphones okay okay that's mmm that's a
free rook okay it's free change but
still Queen here okay no thank you
okay let's let's open the position up
okay
something something nice is happening
here I don't think I have all that much
to be worried about okay
all right queen g3 after captures but
then i pick up the bishop yeah you don't
have the option of doing that okay let's
just go here go here threaten checkmate
okay that's also nice mate how do you
find the mobile app I've never actually
tried accessing a tournament from the
mobile app so maybe maybe someone in the
chest in the chat could help you out but
okay a 400 players so far and yeah seems
like we are going to have a very nice
tournament like I said once my website
is completed I will I will include all
the winners of every other matter arena
chronologically there so you know
whoever won any tournament will be
presented there starting from from our
previous tournament where it was just
really crazy to 2400 players really a
remarkable you know gathering of players
what is the password the password is
YouTube to all capital letters so
YouTube to and okay it's it it tells me
the stream is of excellent health no
it's not no it's not and now it's a
again of mediocre health okay we have
mr. Brody
good luck mr. Brody let's let's see what
happens when we while we wait for the
tournament tournament link is in the
description below as usual okay alright
it's a funky line I guess let's go here
haha yaki after why not let's see let's
see if it's possible unless he moves the
night now then then he tricked me but
then I have queen g4 so I guess I guess
it's all alright ok Queen g4 now if he
goes back
Oh even that that's just mate I guess
alright
why not playing the Kings gambit against
the French that would that would just be
weird and also and also I I don't think
it is possible you can translate the
readers on video I have seen plenty of
people have already translated but thank
you very much
I mean head square quite a nice video
alright
so still 500 and 500 players we do have
a slight slightly different order but
pretty much everything is the same just
don't blunder with a with a 2000 rating
also with a question mark but he just
disappeared so he might be joining us
tournament starts in six minutes
so we do have okay let's see
I'll just go chronologically please
accept pawn pawn for bigger game okay I
will I will for the next one we do have
a couple of more since since everyone is
challenging to a bullet for some reason
okay
I will go for the for the dark square
Bishop is it's a very nice Bishop so
definitely going to grab it
let's go for 'if I've yesterday was New
Year in Iran will have happy belated New
Year to everyone from Iran sorry about
sorry about not mentioning it earlier
all right not really doing anything
special here mostly mostly just trying
to it's a free night positive is Serbia
Dmitri low teach a good game man for
more minutes okay I guess we we do have
time for one more
mr. okay do we have the we have a we
have a X PI X PI also H s supporter you
know it's it's important to keep those
servers servers always running so
everything is always smooth I'm not
making the website myself my my friend
is helping me with it I mean III would
be able to I guess me and mix something
up in WordPress but I don't think it'd
be it'd be something you know to to show
for okay
uneven e5 I guess let's just attack the
night if d5 I will grab it on Poisson
okay that's very impressive it's playing
really fast really really nice ideas
yeah now he will recapture let's just
develop the bishop here bring the rook
into the game maybe another rook on a
one then you'll have to decide what to
do with this night yeah I guess we just
trade on f5 okay if he trades rook I get
a very nice attack going on here let's
straight here or no I don't really gain
anything from trading just okay that's I
guess that's one way to do it
it's definitely one way to do it
yeah I can't go there kind of messed up
here but still I guess it's fine
let's go now I guess mmm not really an
impressive whoa I have to block f2 if
you capture second second one IG 5 10 9
IG 5 okay Queen is guarding that's where
such a sneaky dude I was really really
close couldn't couldn't capture on f7
yeah I forgot the Queen was blocking it
but okay okay
two more minutes yeah I would except
okay let's see do we have any do we have
anyone who claims to be in the chat okay
okay I see her challenge mister I mean I
don't see your challenge D monster but I
remember that even in the previous
streams I was trying to okay that's one
plus five or not we're not having that I
always had problems finding someone in
the in the challenges okay we have a we
have mr. n five seven something with a
question mark so a newcomer newcomer
here okay let's go for that pawn all
right let's try try try a weird idea see
how he reacts okay very happy here okay
I guess yeah he can go for my bishop but
I just grabbed more pieces
okay yup I guess we go here and then
Quinn g4o he's not interested okay he he
figured it out
it's shame
the Rachel mr. mr. veteran mommy okay
that's he just allowed a nice checkmate
but yeah okay we are done with the with
the free challenges we are about to
start the tournament and see what goes
on
so as usual we'll be just checking up on
on the on the stronger games seeing
who's who's doing better in the
tournament
yeah past password is YouTube too but
all capital letters
as usual I'm pretty sure you guys will
get the hang of it as usual you always
do but yeah we're gonna keep keep an eye
on some of my other scores and the the
leisure staff told me that they were
following the previous tournament so if
anyone was caught cheating day and
immediately intervened again I messed up
for I didn't go for the second tab but
we'll remember to do it for next one
yeah blitz but the tournament is blitz
the tournament is not bullet so you
don't have to worry about things like
that mr. Lenoir 34 the link to the
tournament is in the description below
so we're just gonna see monkey school 12
and PT 9 designed brawl it out here it's
gonna be gonna be a really awesome game
you know let let them take care of the
stuff in the beginning then we're gonna
check out what's what's happening mr.
captain Nautilus says tell us the
biggest secret you hold I hold no
secrets man that's that's how I roll
yeah mr. Romans Jones it's also pretty
hot here I have no idea why I mean
shouldn't be like that ah Albanian
potato I'm doing great man
I'm doing great thanks for asking whoo
hope you are well as also all right what
do we have here queens are off the board
black wants to capture and see three
white also has some ideas eater of
infiltrating on these six or capturing
on a seven so it's a very nice idea
that's that's what I like about watching
chess you you can just enjoy it without
without all the all the strain now you
can capture it and go ninety-six but the
roof can also go back to c7 to guard the
bishop so there shouldn't be a problem
yeah you can't capture on f4 hey Thank
You captain Nautilus thank you very much
what is the origin of agate matter well
that I decided to leave that to leave
that out for for some other time maybe
maybe for when when this channel maybe
sometimes reaches 1 million subscribers
as we already mentioned this one's mr.
smart studies just click on the first
link in the description below enter
password YouTube - and and you are all
ready to go for those of you who are new
I will repeat this you don't have to
join from the beginning you can just
join whenever you feel like it
the stream I don't know well the
tournament I've set the tournament to
last one hour and some 10 minutes you
know just so there's it's not too short
for for three-plus soul tournament and
after that I'm gonna be accepting some
challenges as they as they come just you
know to to play a few nice games for a
Friday then maybe hopefully hopefully
grab a beer or something we'll see we'll
see how it goes I know the tournament
doesn't have cash prizes I already
explained it in the previous stream I
decided not to have
cash prizes during these arenas if you
want to call them that way but maybe I
will for every fourth arena like maybe
three arenas in a month without prizes
and then maybe one arena with prizes as
all of you complain that too many title
players show up when there are prizes
and then well it's just I mean if we if
we have paint penguin playing no one
really has a chance of winning the
tournament but on the other hand you
will get you will get a chance to play
against penguin so there's also that
it's not some would consider that a
prize what is the UH nickname on leaches
it's it's almighty I think all over
letters just Almighty to else I believe
mister mister V hon my name is Antonio
so so sorry if I missed your question
okay black infiltrated very nicely we'll
see we'll see if he can if white can do
anything about this it's a he's
threatening to capture the rookin b2
which after rook captures on h2 let's
see how Y deals with it okay white also
has some checkmating ideas if Ruki a
true kid will be checkmate if if and
there really is no way for aa black will
give up the rook for a knight yeah he
had to do that otherwise
checkmate was coming yeah but now we'll
see white doesn't really have a way of
pushing the pawns and black will start
pushing his a pawn I'm very interested
to see how this will turn out such such
an intense game
yeah after I you can't defend the pawn
you can now but should be six the pawn
is defended everything is well yeah it's
gonna be it's gonna be a a game on time
it would seem although the g1 is also
very nice yeah the Jeep one is coming G
two on a light square White has no
chances here whatsoever and you can't
even capture otherwise you lose so an
excellent win for mr. Pete you let's
view the tournament okay we do have
freedom master a little Plotkin and the
freedom master and Nikhil Dixit so even
even without actually having prizes we
do have two two title players joining in
in the previous tournament I believe we
also had two title players it was a a
chess master osseous and and Fida Master
Zipit father is Boston
mr. dref the password is let's check out
the game by little little Plotkin mr.
against mr. Poirot and it seems yes a
little Plotkin has berserk so half of
his time which will make it more
enjoyable as he is much higher rated
some some almost six hundred points
higher hated it's always nice to give
some advantage to your opponent okay
hello from Scotland
the mash of Bulava the the the link to
the tournament is in the description
below so just you know join up cámaras
positive positive no I'm not Italian for
those of you who might be wondering I'm
from Croatia hey Paul hello hello from
Kentucky which is my favorite gambit
line well there are a lot of nice
gambits but I would have to go for the
for the Evans gambit that definitely my
favorite although we you know very
rarely actually see one hey hello from
India also also Greece is here very nice
and chilly chilly Russia Mexico Colombia
very nice well everyone is here
we even have Argentina the next video I
will be publishing today is capablanca
also playing a simultaneous exhibition
in in Buenos Aires Argentina against a
gentleman who I don't know all that much
about but I do have a link to to some
more information about him and for those
of you who are perhaps native Spanish
speakers or you don't have to be native
maybe just understand Spanish really
good I will have something for you to
translate for the rest of us who who
don't really you know speak Spanish so
we can all learn something more about
cup of Blancas opponent so if any we
will have time I know I would be I would
be very grateful for that it seems mr. a
little Plotkin has disconnected this
would be huge he left the game that
would be very unfortunate it would be a
tough loss but also an excellent win for
mr. pero pero is also from Croatia
uh-huh what do you know
but now mr. Plotkin reconnected so no
easy win for you para okay
well Plotkin is definitely putting up
the pressure let's see let's see if you
can do it but wasting a lot of time
night maybe maybe yeah okay yeah you
can't can the night be developed now
it's if you go Queen f3 check can you
can you do something about that yeah now
maybe Queen f3 check but so many nasty
discoveries I don't think it's possible
yeah I don't I don't I don't see it you
could you could I don't I don't know
seems to seems to be the queen is off
yeah and also from Philippines and
Bangladesh
all right yo P you up if I see you in
the summer okay we do have a nice
checkmate so let's let's go back to the
tournament see how we're doing both
little Plotkin and nickel nickel Dixit
our Burger King all of their games
except the first one nickel dynamics
reserved the first one but we do have
dim demon Esther demon Esther from
Algeria he challenged me in the in the
comments but I couldn't fight him and
find him in the challenges so instead
let us check it out how he how he fares
against a freedom master who decided to
berserk against him will he be able to
do it every Shaba you want an update on
the sorcery series well for a very long
time no one no one suggested any any
games that would be fit for a sorcery
series so maybe maybe you can just put
hashtag sorcery No hashtag suggestion
but also have text suggestion maybe
spacebar sorcery and then I would
consider it for my sorcery series but
yeah we'll we'll see how it goes
and haven't really seen a game that
would impress me enough to to use it for
the sorcery series I've never played for
a person chess I don't really I don't
really like it I don't know
I think chess chess is perfect as it is
I don't really like any variations I do
like some like like maybe chess960
that's that's fine
and also Backhouse but okay that's oc5
yeah you can't capture because of
checkmate
that's unfortunate okay white will grab
it and how do you proceed how do you
push
white really wants to win this and he's
he's very much up on time so the feeding
master is in is in a lot of trouble here
and also down down a rook so there's
that rookies rookies coming to d7 and
things are looking looking bleak
doubling yeah just captures and the
other work also joins on d7 it's it's
over
yep demon Esther takes this one very
nicely done and we have yours our of
also playing very nice so two of my
brother-in-law's are are playing
although I don't seek Ronaldinho
anywhere he seems to have you know take
it taking a rest well let's see we have
we have the top game little Plotkin
against yours are but they are already
in the endgame
what can decide it the berserkers are
let's see if he will be able to do it
use our visa is a tough opponent and
also streaming and it's a draw
very nice use out of manages to break
little Plotkin's berserk berserk King
flame alright we have the great or yeah
again we have the top to your game a
little Plotkin versus hms you think that
players cheated know which one I don't
think I don't think so okay let's see oh
we have the halloween' gambit the
Halloween gambit berserk King and also
going for for a nice Halloween gambit
but it seems black does not know the
theory of the Halloween gambit you have
to return the piece this is just no way
no good way to to tackle it not just d5
wins the piece but back so you have to
give back the piece but not like this
yeah okay just twenty five yeah
yeah very nice developing yeah I can see
it I mean using the Halloween gambit
against the low rated players while
berserk King very nice Bishop g5 Bishop
g5 okay I guess we need sex check if the
King goes up Queenie eight will be
checked my but if the King goes to see
six if the King goes to see six then
then the game continues I guess
characters Queenie six or am I missing
something yeah King c6 now okay
b6 I guess you wanna make some room for
your King huh so pretty pretty wild King
hunt black spends a lot of time but b6
seems to be the way to go
okay Queen f6 I don't think so
yeah nice rook lift and that takes care
of the Queen although do you have to
take it you could just go for mate yeah
I think he decided to go for mate
now just Queenie three I guess or that
just bring the King deeper Quincy four
check next and queen bee five will be
will be checkmate very nicely done very
nicely done yeah that Queen f6 was okay
we can go to b6 but then it was the
Queen again no not even that white
doesn't want to grab the Queen okay very
nice mate as you can see the Queen and
pawn are blocking the Kings escape
routes okay what do we have one more
bye-bye Nikhil Dixit let's check it out
also a member of the top three Jurgen
Jurgen used hello from Estonia man
would I recommend any books ah I I would
recommend some chess books yeah when is
the official Ivan Madar website opening
I have no idea the the gentleman who is
currently designing it I mentioned
something about June July so so about
that time but yeah we'll definitely have
a celebration for it and you know it'll
be it will be very nice Hey hello
Bulgaria Thank You mr. remar Zelnick
okay again we have berserk
everyone's Burger King that's why that's
why this three-plus soul okay yeah it's
okay queen of it mate
very nicely done who do we have antic
vs. little Plotkin let's let's check it
out I know it's a yeah it is and both of
them have berserk so this is a this is a
very very feisty game with with a lot of
crazy position on the pieces
huh okay that that white queen is really
really enjoying herself on a 8o
sneaky and giving up a piece so the
Queen could escape not allowing it okay
yep black messed up but it happens
hey hello from Saudi Arabia
mr. Lucas Barbieri I used to have
another job before yes I I used to have
plenty of jobs before and it seems the
the two of them mister little Plotkin
and auntie have played plenty of games
so far as you can see the score is sixty
two twenty eight four four little
Plotkin so a lot of games between the
two of them okay he doesn't want to go
on some rights worse although black
could have captured it
okay now white white just shows that
that that he's better now check you have
to give a bishop and its mate all right
very nice checkmate okay so the
standings are pretty nickel Dixit in
first little Plotkin then diamond Esther
the great use are of young Gautham Oh a
sangee are antic then yet tomorrow and
Marcin - 104 zero and we already have
over 1000 people playing in the arena
1200 people so very nice and forty
minutes to go so I think we'll be
actually having more people which is
always very nice okay well it uh Neal
Dixit versus yours are off let's see
let's see how it goes
Nikhil Dixit berserk okay let's see
characters capture screen I don't know
of course white wants to trade black
isn't interested and black is going very
long time we'll see if he will be able
to okay
white managed to force a trade and now
black shouldn't be shouldn't be able to
to pull this off what it's not a lot of
time on the clock but we'll see equal
material yeah you have to guard the
light square pond with the king so you
can move with the bishop how about all
of you cell responds around dark squares
so I don't I don't see this if anything
use art of could could flag him okay
sneaky sneaky that's such an such a oh
he could have he could have gone for it
okay but I mean okay draw it's a draw
all guys okay very nice draw again
second draw in a row photos are off
let's see and okay we have the the clash
of two leaders efore d5 so the
Scandinavian we'll see we'll see how it
goes
it was the the Scandinavian gambit I
believe yeah as black is already down
upon arriving hello hello from Latvia
and mister mr. Pradeep from India fetus
Ben Khalifa
yeah man you can participate again as
already some 10 minutes have passed just
click on the link in the description
below you will enter the tournament and
use the password that is also in the
description below I don't know maybe
have to click like show more and then
I'll drop down menu will appear okay we
have a nice
whatever it was a nice piece sacrifice
Bishop is coming to g3 so okay black not
allowing get f4 is coming and now a nice
rook lift well we'll see either either
it will work or or it won't theater mode
or fullscreen heights comments well I
guess we're not gonna use those then hey
Marian hello hello from virus mean how
is how is life in virus in hey Jonathan
Daniel it's not about standing a chance
you know it's about it's about having
fun it's Friday you know we're all
having some fun
enjoying some nice chess and it's always
nice when there's a tournament so just
it's not an over the board tournament I
mean nothing in can even remotely relate
to an over the board tournament but you
know it's it's hard to imagine we would
gather 2,000 players in in an over the
board tournament maybe one day who knows
but you know not for now positive
positive all on hostage so yeah all very
nice and captures the edits and very
nice so little Plotkin takes take the
lead I believe yep and also we have the
great one one three two with a perfect
score so fun stuff so far so only little
Plotkin and the great have a perfect
score so far and the demon Esther
although he has a fairly few games
played for some reason maybe he just
plays them really long can I publish the
game from this tournament I could but
you'd have to you'd have to remember
which game it was or or at least send me
the link it will be very hard for me to
to locate any games but ok if we really
see like an impressive one then then we
actually might show it it might not not
be a bad idea
mr. Jurgen mr. Jurgen from Estonia says
I should do another video on Paul Karras
how well we've done plenty of videos on
poor care especially in the 1959
candidate saga but I mean from time to
time we'll also you know get around to
doing a Paul Carrack saga
definitely okay a little Plotkin are
both of them berserk okay so mr. antic
who is a supporter of leeches is not
interested in in being intimidated
Bishop c4 very nice the King has to go
to d8 otherwise it's it's quick work if
oh yeah you have to go to d8
rugby one first yeah not allowing the
king just give me a D file maybe okay
that works
yeah
Queen is coming to g7 maybe we'll see
okay finish five check yeah if not a
fate Bishop h6 is meeting one so that's
not happening ah yes very nice very nice
game bye-bye mr. little Plotkin from
Canada nonetheless
little plot can still in the lead with a
perfect score and he faces gold boozing
I remember mr. gold Goosen from from
some of my previous streams seems he he
still plays chess or nice to hear that
and very nice to hear that mr. Matthew
your first time contribute contributing
the chat it's always it's always
important to contribute as much as
possible to the chat not spamming but
you know a nice crunch at contribution I
see a lot of messages felt for review so
I don't want to even see what's what's
in there okay
mr. little Plotkin berserk against
against busan so we'll see if he can
pull it off its I mean okay berserk king
one two three games it's it's okay but
when you berserk an entire tournament
it's it's very impressive if you can
hold on to that tempo waiting for a
couple Blanca versus last card yeah me
too
it's gonna be it's gonna be a wild one
koala Guzan energy yes yes he is on
blast 69 what is berserk berserk is when
you give your opponent the advantage
like half of your time as you can see
they both started on three plus so and
then when your berserk then you get only
a minute and thirty seconds so but you
get more points if you win so it's it's
a means of gaining more points more
quickly but also you can show off like
that yeah mr. Earl
mr. Earl Grey put it put it very nicely
what is tucked one took swung is when
any move you make will be advantageous
to your opponent maybe not necessarily
lose the game but you know whatever
whatever you do you will mess up your
position one other German word that is
that is being used in chess mr. Joe
first yes man I live in Croatia you're
sort of still in fourth place he's
trying to catch up with to berserk games
but then a loss so he he failed to catch
the flame okay let's let's see how
little Plotkin does it he's facing this
is okay now you see little Plotkin did
not berserk as he's facing an opponent
with a question mark to his rating so
he's not sure if either he's either
thinking maybe he's it's a really strong
player that only created an account only
chess or maybe maybe it's cheater you
never know as he has a question mark
that means he still hasn't played enough
games to to establish a rating here so
it's a it's a very you know cautious
cautious approach
Hey
hello mr. maryland's greetings and
thanks for for joining in from all the
way from Brazil did I invite the hoodie
boy no the hoodie boy couldn't make it
Avalon gaming taught how to see more
quickly in chess well you have to go
through really a lot of diagrams and
just really just solve them you know
without I would out any any cheating or
help just you know try try to solve them
as fairly as possible
like one of the books I could I would
recommend to everyone is a strategy and
tactics by grigory mihaela which list
it's in it's it's a book in three parts
the strategy and tactics our first book
is just really just finding some very
nice tactics then you have second book
is I believe more about strategy and
then third book is finding finding a
viable plan plan of game where there are
no immediate tactics involved I believe
it's been it's been a really long time
since I've gone through them which tile
game am I going to show for for 400k
well there are a lot to choose from and
we did well we had that against Johan
Johan Carter son which was really an
impressive game by tal that we've shown
for 300,000 subscribers so I don't know
we'll see I mean I'm taking suggestions
as usual okay can black do something
here it would be weird if he couldn't
but white white is improving his
position the Queen is preventing
checkmate
so far okay bishop covering f2 white
could be in some trouble not a lot but
some
if yeah how do you block it if Queen
blocks rook captures Bishop and then you
lose the Queen not all now the King has
to go up the board yep
yeah that's it
very impressive very impressive showing
by mr. little Plotkin okay go goes on
again he gets his second opportunity at
the face to face a little Plotkin who
again berserk now we see that it wasn't
just a matter of okay we're already
halfway in the tournament so I'm gonna
stop working but little Plotkin was
actually worried about the question
marks in his opponents rating about the
book did I finish this one let me just
check which one ah nope I did not I did
not finish that that one but you know
any book any book is a good book if it's
a book on chess so I still haven't found
a book that wasn't you know enjoyable
[Music]
why am I not playing well if I had like
a like someone else a co-host the hosts
the tournaments I might but it's a
subscribers tournament it's the figure
out who is the strongest among
subscribers and I'm taking challenges
before and after this tournament and it
would it would prevent me from enjoying
the chat and you guys are so cool in the
chat you know it's very enjoyable so
it's better better this way you know the
subscribers brawl it out and I enjoyed
the chat and then I accept some
challenges later that way that way
everyone wins okay nicely doubled rooks
can-can f5 somehow happened not likely
96 okay the roofs are getting traded off
and now f5 is coming up
huh again with a sneaky check mr. little
Plotkin hey thanks a lot mr. paper man
faketaxi is the best okay if we if we
see him his game somewhere we're
definitely gonna check it out how is
called my dog my dog is called meadow
mr. root week ready happy birthday man
covermore Nakamura's games well we will
have a couple of tournaments now where
Nakamura is playing so we will I will
cover some of them as most of them are
are enjoyable tall versus Leon each time
which game versatile versus Leon each
time is my dog alive yeah he's he's
right there I think he always hides
behind me what do I do in my free time
except chess well a lot of things you
know I try to get my exercise as as most
of you I imagine I you know walk my dog
I go out for a beer I enjoy some board
games I enjoy some some video games you
know you know also doing useful stuff
whenever I can just you know anything
you know maybe a book here here and then
when I whenever I get the chance
well there are a lot of things to do but
not enough time to do whatever you want
and mr. Gholson seems to have decided to
flag little Plotkin let's see what
little Plotkin has to say about that
Oh even a queen trade this is a an
impressive move you see little Plotkin
decides to trade Queens even though he
has five seconds on the clock because he
is very confident in his endgame skills
that's why you should always study the
endgame okay it's a king hunt can can
black do it white is trying to check
made him but safer okay that was a free
queen huh white is trying to flag him so
hard that it does he even gave up his
Queen and okay we have the first loss by
mister little Plotkin Rollo goes and
breaks through and which is weird since
the goal rosin is nowhere near the top
10 hour we do have him here and it's
little Plotkin versus yours out of let's
see little pot can just lost the game
and now he berserk is it is it a raging
berserk or is it just a well-thought-out
berserk we'll see II five I like little
Plotkin style but we'll see we'll see if
you can do it okay
I see two
very very active play
yeah that's pretty much it Mistral gray
that's that's the password your password
is losing fantastically we like hover
the European Chess Championship in
Skopje definitely I will cover some of
the games we'll see so far I haven't I
think they've already played three or
four rounds yeah but I didn't see you
guys
suggesting any games from from the
European Chess Championship hey hello
hello sir sergio from Costa Rica
Mario Laura salute man any info on Leela
vs talk to chef I've stopped following
it I've only been following the 100 game
match with which stockfish one with a
half a point margin but after that I
haven't really been following it okay
little Plotkin I mean doing doing
excellent what can what can use are of
do here and that yeah better give up the
rook
it would seem and now Oh
protect the f2 pawn now you have to
guard the g6 pawn how do you do that
quite quite the quite the player mr.
little Plotkin yeah man
mr. Pugh good luck on your economics
exam I wouldn't want to be in your in
your spot what did I think of Carson
give me black moves first well it's you
know it's it's a nice gesture I wish I
had the moves to show the game although
I don't think they actually played the
game I think they just made a few moves
just to make the recording how I stopped
smoking mr. Lawry toes yes I stopped
smoking like I don't know how long is
it's been so far
maybe some eight months maybe more any
video on beating the ejection defense
well I can't remember making any from
the from the top of my head at the
moment but he doesn't want the pawn that
was that was strange why not capture the
pawn yeah little Plotkin breaks through
berserk in years art of wonderful
wonderful move demon Esther still
undefeated but with with the least games
played and we have another player
catching up it's mr. tars eight also
undefeated so yeah
let's see let's see how it goes another
challenger to a little Plotkin is it mr.
big money so let's see how he does
and Plotkin also berserks
yeah I could I could also make a video
where black moves first by making some
sort of a triangulation maybe with the
Knights in the beginning of the game
like okay the PGN is this but I could
just maybe you know flip the Knights
around little Plotkin already one very
nice
a queen blunder and then I could just
make it a blacks move even though really
it wasn't black smooth but it is
possible to do it
yeah that ended abruptly let's see how
mr. demon Esther is playing but he's not
playing at the moment so his opponent is
uh I'm just refresh that I think this
yeah it's the interface is a bit weird
but let's see what would your reaction
be if one of your subscribers just
visited you randomly I don't think
that's really possible since no one
knows where I live it's like it's like
totally top-secret location even though
I live in a really small city you know
it would be it would be very very hard
to find me not not I don't think it
would be possible
I thank you mr. Sultan that'd be awesome
but maybe if there would be money money
prices then they would join I don't
think they would join just for fun
but we are going we will definitely have
some money prizes I decided like I said
not not to make every every arena with
money prizes but like every every fourth
in a month I guess it would it couldn't
hurt for some more more title players to
join up it's a three night definitely
but first first there was a 24 check
included for some reason Bishop versus
Knight how to play the endgame okay
we're definitely gonna cover that as
well although there are plenty of videos
on YouTube that cover that so I think
you're you know you're well off there
but I am planning to make a video fairly
soon on how to how to approach teaching
chess to to complete beginners trying to
make it interactive and trying to make
it not about in the openings at all
trying to make it a solely about the
principles and if you can do that that
then well you have to just make the
other person enjoy chess then everything
else will follow easily if you don't if
you know if you're not able to do that
Oh Queen g3 by black would be excellent
now if black had move but he doesn't
yeah so that's that's something I'm
planning we'll see how it goes
yeah he had to resign can I do the fish
response kiri match yes I will
definitely do that I decided not to do
it immediately after the Fisher saga but
when I finally do cover that event when
I finally do cover it you know we're
just gonna add it to the playlist so it
will be again a Complete Saga
oh it's mr. Littlefinger we have we have
a Game of Thrones fan maybe who who is
who is excited for Game of Thrones
coming out soon that's something that's
something enjoyable in April I guess
Game of Thrones and also Avengers and
game will I also cover the story around
the 1992 rematch as well
of course I mean that's the most
important part do I prefer Petrosyan or
Smith's love I'd have to go with with
Tigran yes who is the greatest chess
player of all time I that's uh that's
impossible to answer but you know I'm
sure I'm sure the chat will have no
problems giving you an answer do i watch
TV shows other than Game of Thrones I
don't watch any new ones No
from time to time I will I will rewatch
some of the shows that I found enjoyable
when I was younger like maybe like Star
Trek for example or maybe I've just
reached all serious seasons of friends
that was that was very nice also enjoy
How I Met Your Mother I don't know a lot
of them really but none I don't enjoy
none of the newer ones they're just
they're just lame
yeah no not not Baywatch okay this I
literally just looked the other way to
see the chat and the game is over a
little plot can want it in in four
seconds very nice
let's let's check up on some other games
okay so far we have 14 more minutes in
the tournament a little Plotkin with
only one loss it was a loss to go low
boozing then mr. Nikhil Dixit demon
Esther there's something very odd about
demon Esther he is undefeated so far but
he's playing very slow it's
well it's just weird
better call Saul no I haven't seen
better call Saul but I have seen the
original series from from where Saul is
I think it's also by the Russo brothers
it's the idea Arrested Development the
character sole is originally from that
show I believe Kasparov vs. carpel World
Chess Championship yeah I mean we will
cover that but that would I don't know
that's that's such a huge saga which
take us a year to cover that
yeah Breaking Bad I've seen Breaking Bad
but I like the first three seasons then
they just lost me posters of Rob
Hashanah
thanks mr. magician
have I ever watched Vikings yes I have
I've seen the first two seasons and
already the second season I didn't
really agree with me it's like it's like
something they do they just make a nice
first season to sell the show and then
they just start doing something else and
just you know yeah we have money let's
let's make the the shows happen but
they're they're basically garbage ah
better call Saul is the spinoff of
Breaking Bad okay yeah I guess I messed
up something yeah thanks for that
do I still play League of Legends no I
don't it's just I have I have a big
problem with League of Legends they just
keep changing the game and then it's
something I really don't enjoy
I was I was fairly decent in league not
like great I was I think the the
farthest I got was gold one I got called
on it was like promotions for platinum I
almost reached platinum so not not not a
great player but I did enjoy it but then
they just keep changing it I remember I
basically stopped playing it they they
nerfed they did a nerf Katarina they
just changed her and I was like I'm not
gonna learn how to play all over again
so I decided now maybe maybe it's time
to quit I do I do play maybe an R I'm
known then but that's about it
dota yeah I was never never a dota
player I did play the old dota on
Warcraft a worker of three but never the
actual daughter game I did try to but
since I tried League first I didn't
really care for dota later
Joe Jonas Luffy Paulson and okay the
queen is at the board let's see okay
white will not give black a hard time he
decides to resign okay and demon ester
with his first loss he lost to Cahoon
and Cahoon also with only one loss
against lb on red n it's a but still
with a question mark so let's see I
think we'll have to just a lot of
players streaming this tournament mr.
hockey on also streaming but I don't see
him anywhere in the top ten and again a
clash of leaders although mr. little
Plotkin is 20 points ahead of everyone
else so I don't think it will be
possible to to do it amazing maze couple
Blanca versus are you yes we will cover
that but we will not cover it during the
capablanca saga as that match is a part
of a lien saga you know alright I don't
know both of them berserk again and we
have white is up a night so it's I don't
think it's a it's it's even possible but
then now they're entering a bullet area
anything can happen you want to play in
a 15 plus 10 rapid match yeah I think
that's a that's a bit too much for for a
stream have I seen a Lucifer yes I've
seen I've tried watching it maybe I've
seen six episodes maybe maybe five or
six it was okay but not nothing I would
continue watching I haven't seen ozark
all other has several people who have
recommended it but I haven't had time to
check it out
Thank You mr. see see that a sous cloth
have I ever seen peaky blinders no I
haven't nor nor the office US version
the blacklist okay
I mean those are all very nice
suggestions I'll definitely give it a
try okay this is now we're entering some
very impressive chess area here but with
such little time on the clock it will be
impressive how white will win this black
is trying to control everything but it's
just okay now okay even with 17 seconds
on the clock white will win this having
having a knight is just a bonus okay and
there we have it a very nice checkmate
by mr. Nikhil Dixit but like we said 74
points to 258 although Nikhil Dixit is
getting the flame now so I guess it
might be possible but then again Plotkin
will also berserk every game I I don't I
don't see it happening
okay
Damone Esther in third place with a very
impressive tournament although yeah it's
normal for for a little Plotkin and
nickel Dixit to have so many games
played since they berserk every game but
that's just just the way it is let's
let's check out this one
how old am i I am 31 at the moment can I
do a video on sorry
Neha siren versus firoozeh which game my
favorite 13th century archbishop I don't
I don't I don't have a favorite yet I'm
still deciding between a few you know do
people celebrate Halloween in Croatia
yeah yeah that yes they do we will
definitely have an Akiba rubenstein saga
but I think I think Ben Feingold
actually made a well sort of a rule in
soccer I know he was making some videos
on the gentleman yeah Rick and Morty is
nice I enjoy working Morty although I
still haven't seen all of them maybe I'm
still stuck on the first season
do I play any instruments well I I dunno
oh very nice but after this it's okay
just a rook yeah I do I do play the
guitar although I haven't played it in a
very long time and well I I am hoping to
start start learning a piano sometime
soon not a real piano is I mean where
would I get one but maybe maybe just a
synth or something
Kappa Blanc or morphe well that's not
really something to choose from I mean a
little plot in winds as he's so much up
ahead in material Nikhil Dixit still not
how okay I really have to figure out how
to get it get some other games aha okay
you just hover over it and then the game
appears okay and again okay as it is a
clash of leaders I guess we can check it
out okay it was not the Norwegian
defence it was it was gg6 Bishop g7 but
yeah that H bone just marched up forward
so we'll see and again both of them
berserk I have not played go I actually
haven't met anyone that plays it for me
to try it out and I don't know I didn't
I I didn't want to play it online
can I speak any other language aside
from English well I know some german
deutsch if you will I mean I can
understand it but I don't really I don't
really speak it as well I don't go to
Germany and pretty much no one here
speaks German but I did study it in
school and yeah that's that's about it I
have I've tried I've tried learning some
some Korean just you know the alphabet
and some no simple words but that's
about it
why do I always make jokes on the Evans
gambit it's not a joke it's it's it's
basically I'm very sad that it wasn't
played but it's no joke and wow what a
nice rogue blunder but it's definitely
no joke what okay black resigns which
makes sense what do we have here okay
you're sort of manages and managed to
climb up to the top ten let's see how
he's doing okay he's doing well he will
win this game as his opponent is out of
time very nice let's just go back to the
tournament yours out of climbs up to
fifth place and it yeah might be might
be luck likely that he can maybe climb
up to the top three but we'll see we'll
see if he can do it let's see he's still
not getting a game everyone's busy in
game so let's check out on a little
Plotkin against mister cyclonite who
also reserved that's how it's done
just berserk 500 rating stronger
opponent and you know nothing nothing
bad can happen
yeah I mean it was a nice root blender
yeah I will accept some challenges after
the tournament not sure how many we'll
see yeah I mean I do have to when I when
I don't correctly set up the sound
before recording the video then I have
to well reduce the volume so you don't
hear a double double sound from the
moves okay
and now very nice
okay little Plotkin is giving this a
thing how do you do this is it even
possible
nope that that kinks position on f3
makes it very very oh you can't even pin
it yeah ow
that was a fine attempt but the King on
f3 just makes it weird and the Plotkin
will actually lose this
so mr. cyclonite very impressive
no he won't okay he found a he found an
idea yeah check and it's a it's a
perpetual okay well it was it was it was
a very nice game but it seems it seems a
perpetual is in order and a lot of
ratings lost on there to draw okay I
don't know who is playing even if you
Sarah wins but he
seem to be in-game yes he is in-game but
still it will not be enough yeah he
could actually get 5 points so he could
get 4th place I will just see since the
the tournament is over now and yeah and
there you have it
we're just gonna wait a few seconds as
the system filters out any potential
cheaters although I don't think we will
be having any but just in case you know
until all games are finished but their
little Plotkin would with a truly
impressive performance would at 2276
perform it's only one game lost no two
games lost story and with a berserk rate
of 96% percent but Nikhil Dixie would a
100 percent berserk rate yeah little
Plotkin the only game hidden berserk was
that one against the the question mark
player can't remember who it was
maybe tars maybe it was stars it was
just well-being
being careful I guess will I make a
cautionary saga yeah sure but it seems
it seems that everything is in order now
I think all the games are finished
so yeah in first place we have missed
mr. Vitti master a little Plotkin with a
performance of 2276 23 games played 83%
win rate 96% berserk rate as you can see
2nd place Fila master Nikhil Dixit 2187
performance 22 games played win rate 73
% berserk rate 100 and then demon Esther
who played only 15 games much less but
he did not berserk so it's to be
expected that his games will last longer
93 % win rate so the highest win rate
amongst the the highly placed and 0
presenters are great and among the other
top 10 we have the great in 4th place
the great one 1:32 then yours are off
who was almost at the top about
had a few bumps in the road then car
honk in sixth mind with seven cyclonite
who would that impressive draw against
little clock in the final round goal
goes on in ninth and mr. tars 8th in
10th place as usual I will announce the
winners on all of my social media so you
know when you see it
be sure to congratulate them as it's
always nice to congratulate the winners
if you want the tournament you would
want people to congratulate you as well
so you should always do that whenever
someone wins anything you know even even
a funny reward you know always
congressionally players so we had a
fewer people in this tournament than in
the previous one 1500 players but still
an impressive event since I wasn't
really announcing it or anything so very
very very kind of all of you to show up
and make this such a such a great event
so that's it like I said don't forget to
congratulate the winners and now for the
four you know just enjoying it a bit
let's check out a few a few challenges
they can be any time format maybe maybe
just don't make it longer than than
three possible but ok we have daemon
Esther here with a three plus so
challenge since he was in the in the top
three let's let's accept the challenge
from daemon Esther good luck good luck
to you sir mr. demon Esther from Algeria
won third place in this very nice event
all right
ok so I guess it's only fair to go 95
yep and he wants to go for this line and
he knows this line very well obviously
yep let's let's go
ok
let's just castle
let's go d4 try and open up the center
oh my opponent wants to take back a move
okay which move do you want to take back
b6 yeah okay
obviously b6 though there was no a real
real reason to go in b6
since what you really want to take care
of is the hay is the c6 bone okay that
allows me to bring my rook into the game
maybe also also the bishop so how do we
how do we proceed here let's just grab
that one or better yet let's not there's
always time to grab the pawn
yeah let's go here huh gonna be a really
really weird game but I mean why not um
okay let's just let's just deliver a
nice check here
what words the knight gonna go with the
King attacks it not really interested in
that maybe not the not the best giving
up with the bishop like this you could
block with the Queen might have messed
up here but we'll see
we'll see what he has to say about this
okay he immediately runs away with the
king
I guess that's also that's also playable
how do we proceed do I mind him grabbing
this with the king I don't think I do
huh let's just capture that first he
successfully escaped escaped with the
king but you know he did take third
place in the tournament so so definitely
definitely a good player okay yeah I do
I do have to go back I I recognize it
now I'm just down a piece okay that was
that was a poor showing on my part but
what are you gonna do yeah I know now
it's lost but I mean I missed I missed I
was I would be down a piece you know it
happens okay let's let's try at least
and get our rooks active we'll see we'll
see what it does okay let's go nope
let's push this
I could go I could go rook e8 force
there should be seven but no I'm waiting
for him to move the bishop yes I want to
play this I want to play this
he will capture here and what do we do
now let's go here yep not the greatest
[Music]
really really annoying
okay good game sir
good game mr. demon Esther very nice
yeah there you have it you it is even
possible to lose a game in this line
with white as you've seen so very nice
congratulations man
that was that was very enjoyable do we
have some do we have anyone else from
the from the tournament in the
challenges these are all all bullet do
you want to leave the site yes good game
man
yeah I don't know if you will be able to
write it Stratis strategy and tactics by
grigory me hollow soliciting but yeah it
is possible okay let's just grab bond
here last time I grabbed this pawn I
didn't have a great game but it's a pawn
I mean I will grab it again just castle
here okay
huh for that room back let's go here
capture here or not
yup okay let's just double up here
let's see if we can win the other look
as well yeah that's the the power of the
bishop here let's just straight here
okay good game man over the Cochran
gambit
not not really sure okay this the this
is a two days challenge
I missed a free pawn now okay it will
happen okay we have a bullet from mr.
little Plotkin okay let's do it mr.
little Plotkin an ice bullet game
against the winner of the tournament
let's see good luck to you mr. mr.
Plotkin let's try and do something here
okay let's go here most likely he will
capture that okay and if I just grab the
night what then I go here you have to go
back and now I developed my other pieces
yeah okay thank you sir let's get the
night into the game and also the rook
it's quite an important piece if I can
get Queen d2 I win but he didn't allow
it unfortunately okay so I'm up a piece
but he seems like he knows his way
around let's let's break through here
okay how do I get my silly Knight into
the game yeah those three pawns are
strong definitely gonna have to consider
getting rid of one of them yeah
I can't do this let's try but not likely
come on
lame-o he's gonna destroy me okay but
now house how to see we know yeah he can
just
checkmate me oh come on nope no way
around it
good game man oh that was that was
intense
okay usually no rematches but as mr.
Plotkin won the tournament he gets a
rematch good luck sir oh that was
intense
that was intense from mr. Plotkin quite
quite a deadly player okay he's
constantly doing these weird maneuvers I
will grab the Rope sir gladly
okay nope no you don't let's develop
this this trying Castle if he goes f6f-5
to release the bishop
I can't really say I mind let's try and
trade here okay so yes I will trade
let's go here and go here have to play
faster he's really okay might have made
a mistake here what just happened here
it's like she plays two moves in a row
oh yeah I want to play I mean I don't
want to play Bishop here it's really
weird
let's escape play f3 now I do have to
capture
okay mr. Plotkin is a Wow
okay I just blundered but deadly player
deadly player
okay that's so lame no and the points of
the of the correct color I was hoping it
wasn't okay mr. Plotkin you want another
rematch okay one more one more against
mr. Plotkin what he's he's a a deadly
opponent that's okay what do we go for
here let's think of the other side
okay let's just okay we can try it that
way
huh yeah I guess I guess that's fair
maybe this immediately Oh fuff of crazy
crazy stuff and go here go here okay
let's go here not even possible to get
this guy away from there
okay oh it's a nice check Wow well he is
he's up material so I guess it it makes
sense to go for it
okay now you trade yeah there's no way
no way around it
okay good game man good game and a
well-deserved victory in both both the
the bullet games against me and ended
the tournament but we do have we do have
other challengers as well thanks thanks
for the for the lessons man honest
moktari
well there are there are over a hundred
challenges so I will not be able to go
about them separately I'll just go as
they come or maybe from the bottom side
let me just check from the bottom okay
Phillips's from the bottom yeah I did
have a an opportunity in game number one
but it it got out of hands too quickly
it was already tournament but not
anymore probably gonna capture
yeah you try winning one single game man
all right
Oh huh you know he's gonna play see
three kinda messed up here but I'm gonna
attack the night so I guess there's that
okay he did grab the rook I'll give him
that he was able to do that let's try it
like this
not not the best idea but not not a lot
to choose from and I can't even pick up
the bishop since he has Queen Queen here
which is unfortunate
okay let's try blocking it yeah all
right
it's been a long day
let's at least grab something back okay
let's go here at least block block it
somehow I'm okay we are doing quite well
in time so there's also that let's try
this and okay that's that's a free Queen
we were able to do this at least ok good
game man was able to trick you on that
one
yeah you know how you know how it is the
shorter the time control the the worse I
play as I'm not all that all that
impressive indeed in the openings
with vtt we okay we already had a game
against VTT I remember we accepted the
challenge before the tournament
good game mister Abin eyes a bear Momo
paws are what we lose on a poster man
good to see you
okay it seems like mr. a bonus is not
here so we will we're just gonna abort
that game three plus two okay we have a
we have a three plus zero against mr.
helmet no it's not too late to join in
you want me to speak something in
creation what do you wanna hear tell me
what do you want to hear and I will I
will translate it for you okay we have a
a nice genuine tonight's tonight's
defense game okay let's go
d4 here Queen c7 I guess f4 know he's
gonna castle to change the color of the
board
why what's what's wrong with the color
it seems like it seems like a nice a
nice color can just go c4 since he
allows it
mm-hmm that's really it's weird moved by
mr. helmet but then again how many
leeches tears I have opened not not that
many okay I guess we do grab the rook he
he somehow missed that and let's just
keep on developing
there should be seven I guess
well this is a good as time as any to
grab a bone I will not translate gold
Goosen as you can translate that very
well for yourself okay let's just
develop some of the pieces anywhere I
guess that bishop pair is nice although
he's done a piece but I do have to be
somewhat careful Queen f7 okay
let's defend that's e4 pawn okay let's
do it like this try and get our Queen
into the game and the other rook that
might be a nice idea how about a hello
everyone well you hear that plenty of
times I don't think there's a need for
that
let's bring the Queen into the game if
he grabs the bishop I don't mind I just
open up my F file but yeah that's the
move I was worried about if he actually
went for that which he did so good for
him I guess he's trying to get the Queen
somehow to join the attack although so
far I don't think it will be possible
yeah okay you can do that then I have to
force the Queen back and now get my
queen out of the way maybe even give up
a bishop for for some action here yeah
okay let's see if it's possible get rid
of one of his rooks also pressure the
night
you want me to translate capablanca
didn't know any opening theory
Capablanca Nemo for more xxx Warren yeah
nicolai - you're off to have a beer
that's that's always nice to hear man
okay let's grab that I don't see the
idea behind this night sacrifice to tell
you the truth but then again okay it's
just let's let's attack it again and now
we okay after that I'll kick the night
away go Knight f5 and get the King out
of here I guess yeah we should
definitely try and get the King out of
this diagonal now I'd like to get Queen
night somewhere maybe not even h5 but I
have to somehow get rid of his bishop
okay you do have that I guess you do
have that so let's try it this way you
can go f5 maybe Queen protects and again
I'm down I'm down on time it's just very
very not enjoyable night goes here now
we do this do we do this now if I have
four attacking the Queen I can attack
his Queen although I'm not getting
anything for it so let's just go here
now if he trades Queen guards the g2
square so I'm happy about that
let's still guard it like this it's a
very intense game okay let's try to
throw grab grab his Queen although for
for two pieces I don't think it will be
all that impressive okay
let's prevent him from going there ah
such such little time on the clock
okay I see what you did there yeah you
can have the rook oh man of stuff okay
Wow
I lost in time good game man good game
definitely bullet is not my forte here
at least not today sometimes sometimes I
have a good bullet day you can't join
the tournament the tournament is over
but you are welcome to join everyone
else beating me it's it's it's a bit
target matter festival it would seem but
yeah okay we have a feels good man
clapping but with a 2 plus 1 and we have
grammatical I always will accept the
challenge from dramatic of one of my
first subscribers yeah time time for
kamigami yeah I'm not that great but so
it's easier when you don't stream try to
trick him into winning his Queen early
but also always nice to play before ok
let's go here maybe develop the knight
[Music]
huh okay let's harass this Queen even
further like this what's this move it's
a really weird move
okay let's let's try something like this
let's try something like that okay now
this
we got the king to join in and now we
prevent him from escaping that's that's
how you do it okay he picks up the night
but he doesn't yeah let's just we I
guess we we could win the Queen or we
just capture here threaten this I'm not
missing anything or Queen d1 if he
prevents it so could be very nice okay
he does that I guess we can capture here
yes here let's just eliminate a few
pieces how do we do that
no idea Oh that'll work but I almost
decided to do something terrible so good
game grammatical oh let's let's let's
have a three plus oh yeah I think I
think that's that's that's a bit better
against mr. big money big money I've
seen big money playing in the tournament
okay where did I get the name of a
matter I I made it up it was it was it
was a one-time inspiration and it it
just stuck
let's go here yeah will not we will not
be making a saga video right now okay he
obviously expected that what I mean it
was to be expected um yeah just got
lucky one get night here maybe there
maybe go somewhere we'll see
yeah let's kick him to h5 maybe attack
it again or if he captures just nice
developing move okay pawn captures he
could play d4 but not really something
that interests me oh he wants to he
wants to prepare it but okay now I will
react to it now okay but now I just
blundered the e5 pawn that's or or did I
hmm okay I guess that's one way to do it
captures now I do this or do I need to
do it
with the Queen okay
the material is not equal because he
just grabbed my pawn but we will get a
nice some nice activity going on so so
there's that he also grabs another pawn
yeah that's what I do definitely well
yeah let's just let's just put some
pieces in front of his King and see what
happens maybe maybe something good will
happen
whereas daughter the engine boy daughter
the engine boy is very busy now he he
got married and and is expecting a baby
so now he has no time to be Oh kind of
missed that kind of missed that but it
doesn't seem to be too big of a deal
still have some some nice ideas g6 is
coming definitely let's let's go here
but what do we do after that it doesn't
seem to be an appropriate move after
that we could go rook f1 I guess yeah
let's go here trade first rook F 1 we
can't straight yeah now look at fun now
I guess we could trade maybe hmm not not
an impressive okay now it's just a
blunder but what are you gonna do okay
good again man managed the trick of
their mr. big money but yeah I didn't
give up a lot of points but that's what
I meant
just put the night in front of the King
and see what happens we have what we
have
mr. standard okay let's we do have a few
people Pedro's challenges mr. deck to
say yeah I will he's not I don't think
he's not in Croatia at the moment okay
let's try and trick him into into losing
the Queen but no he figured it out
okay let's just go back put the night he
could go if five not really something
that worries me okay now I will grab it
try and get the Queen into the game and
now I just have to figure out how to how
to activate my rooks okay let's go d5
not okay now he definitely has a nice
setup to do have to deliver checkmate
not all that worried just yet yeah let's
just we'll have to give up some material
at least if he goes back I can go g6
so it's not all that big of a deal once
he trades but ya know he first has to
take care of this checkmating idea which
he missed so there's there's that it's
honest in the demo okay man I will see
if it's anywhere near but there are so
many challenges it's hard to it's hard
to pinpoint them three plus two okay
okay let's just clear clear the bullet
ones first I guess but I don't think mr.
vtt is here as he's been challenging for
quite some time now
oh he's here okay let's let's try and go
for this one and yeah remember if there
are any Spanish speakers in the chat for
my next video which I will be releasing
after I finish the stream I do have a
short article I would like for you to
translate and at the comment section so
everyone can enjoy as we do have a
little bit of information and a couple
lockers opponent I just wasn't able to
figure out what it said
unfortunately okay let's just grab this
go here Thank You Eduardo if it's
possible you know just translate it drop
it in the comments and I will I will pin
your comment to give it a heart you know
so everyone else can enjoy it as well
okay just grab here I don't want to
castle some Bishop h7 ideas might be
possible so let's let's waste a move
first as it is a bullet all right
yes I will grab that okay now he's just
too low one time to do actually do
anything okay
okay friend okay
good game man capture night yeah I don't
know I I like my bishop there mr. Gore
it's a anima P all right man yeah
mr. silent modus well not really a
childhood much more of a high school
days friend we might say okay it's a
nice nice three minute game let's
immediately go for for this nice let's
say something like a stone wall set up
[Music]
can the next tournament be one minute
well there was a poll and you guys were
voting on which format you would prefer
and everyone voted for for a three
minute tournament so I don't think
that's that's actually a problem or
anything
I think but most of you guys enjoy it
okay and f3 that's an interesting
weakening of the position so I guess we
pile up on the e3 pawn now get some
rooks in there
also the ship is coming here yes I will
grab that thank you
if King captures then I can just if King
captures what do I do
Bishop captures okay it's fair it's fair
let's do it like if I do it like this
you push a pawn I can't allow that I
can't allow that but I can double up for
for the D pawn okay that's that's just
weird
why would you do that yeah I think after
rook afraid but then King goes back yeah
I mean check okay fair
let's block
mr. Alex Gilson I don't know if you are
an excellent subscriber I can tell you
that only you can know that okay well we
definitely don't want to blunder some
mate so let's just capture I mean play
h6 prepare captures if he doesn't move
it it's really a funny funny position
okay
I don't want him to to be able to
actually block this pawn so I'll just
push it okay it's one way to do it
okay very well
she can go she can't go anywhere now
with the bishop because he loses the
pawn and the point is on a nice nice
dark square so the bishop is not a
problem yeah he can do that but now what
was my idea here I don't think I had any
don't think I had any yeah it's just I
still have to take care of this pawn my
fee goes rook if one not all that
impressive
a forever and always good night good
night okay he blocked this way
oh let's let's go here try and take this
away I think he should have gone for
rook to f1 it'd just be better
[Music]
yeah I definitely should go for a beer
thanks man and I do intend to what just
happened here I somehow missed my queen
what oh he played it and I just played
wow that's okay
good game man I think I think I'm pretty
much too tired for this again but yeah
no no I'm too tired since I didn't even
I didn't even see that that I blundered
that yeah so it seems that it is
definitely time to end the stream as
yeah it's impossible to play like this
but I did enjoy it nevertheless you know
it would be it would be silly to say
otherwise
so yeah I will end the stream with this
glorious defeat but like I said I will
be publishing my next couple Blancas
game after so for all of you who are a
native Spanish speakers please try to
translate it I will also mention it in
the video to remind you it will be the
first thing you see in the link in the
description so I will do everyone a huge
favor if you translated the article not
word by word but maybe just what it says
in short so that's that's the stream I
do hope you enjoyed it a lot of you have
beaten me so I'm pretty sure you have
enjoyed it yeah thank all for watching
and I will see you soon in a couple of
minutes since I'm publishing the video
soon see you soon guys have an excellent
rest of your weekend